Griffin with Griffin
and you know how we do so let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
live on a Wednesday
YouTubers thank you for being here
today I went and saw barbie I got Rachel
to go see Barbie and so we saw that so I
have a full review of that big brother
25 I love big brother but it's a hot
mess
plus a bunch of other news and notes and
weird stories from around the world but
once again
[Music]
thank you
yeah voice is feeling milky today y'all
milky voice today so I'm glad we got
that out the way welcome back to riffing
with Griffin and remind me
um
yeah so wait you know what before I even
get into all that you know we don't want
to see that yet because that's not
supposed to be there yet it's supposed
to be something else yeah there we go
see I did it
um yeah we'll go back to River with
Griffin y'all
um as you know you know thank you please
subscribe
hit the Subscribe button y'all hit that
subscribe and get the notifications so
you know when I'm going live
um you know what I mean so thank you uh
for that and you know if you're on
Twitch you want to see me on Twitch game
my game every day Eric Griffin gaming I
also have a gaming channel on YouTube
Eric Griffin gaming is also on YouTube
where I lied I put up a lot of like the
you the twitch content if you don't like
twitch or you don't have twitch I put my
gaming videos up there so make sure you
watch that and extra content coming to
patreon as you know but you could be a
patreon member YouTube member or twitch
subscriber and you'll get you know the
Eric Griffin content so thanks for that
thanks for coming out guys I got some um
I got some some dates coming up so you
know and uh just be on the lookout for
that I'm actually gonna go do a lot of
shows with Matt Rife uh my good buddy
Matt because he's doing a new Netflix
special and I'm gonna be like like
helping him produce that so I'm gonna go
on do some Road dates and you know help
him you know organize his set and that
kind of stuff you know throw some ideas
off of me and you know what I mean I
just like helping that kid because he's
like he really did it he made it but in
terms of me uh so I got those dates but
they're already sold out so it don't
even matter
that man good kid but I'm gonna be in
the ice house if you are in the Los
Angeles Pasadena area I'm doing one show
at the Ice House on August 17th you can
go to my website aaron.com and get your
tickets now you know
you know what I mean you could go get
your tickets now at ericgriffin.com you
know my terrible website I'm still
working on it but I'm also coming to
Kansas City August 24th through the 26th
so if you're in Kansas City area check
me out and then September 7th through
the 9th I'm gonna be at the Comedy Zone
Jacksonville and I got some more dates
coming up but those are the most recent
ones that are coming up and uh you know
check back for like changes in that so
thanks for uh coming out guys
um today's episode yeah man I'm uh I
went and saw barbie so that's the update
of the week right now is that um
Rachel was feeling good the you know the
the nausea comes and goes someday she's
feeling sick you know but
the other day we had a nice breakfast
and then we went to the movies and we
saw Barbie
um
so I'll tell you about that I have a big
Barbie my big Barbie review so stay
tuned for that
um yeah
yeah and that's pretty much my the
pregnancy update uh for that you know
we're Trucking along I like how like you
had these these great pregnancy apps and
they'll tell you your baby is as big as
an avocado today
I don't know
I guess that for scale I guess if you're
you're looking at stuff and you're like
what's the scale of the like like then
it'll be like oh your baby's an onion
you know you're just kind of like what
is this cool so that that's cool stuff
going on and uh I got some weird stories
too I want to talk about uh this this
the mayor of Anchorage and there's this
you know internet stuff and uh just some
weird Instagram stories and stuff that's
going on out there in the world too but
like but for the most part you know the
pregnancy is going going well man you
know I know there was this oh when I get
to the comments I'll get to those next
it's it's funny either I'll get to the
comments but there was this one just
weird comment but you know it's just
that's just that's just the internet man
um you know and I and I I have a story
that gonna lead me into what I'm gonna
talk about when it comes to the internet
uh but you know I'll get to that I'll
get to my Soliloquy about that so
um
there's already already nonsense in the
chat this this idiot why would any man
watch Barbie unless he has a daughter
like okay so because you have a wife or
a girl or you do a podcast where you
review movies and you wanna you know do
a do this or you're curious because it's
one of the fastest movies to reach a
billion dollars and you want to see what
all the hype is there's a Litany of
reasons other than your dumb archaic I'm
a man so I'm a man everybody I'm a man
and I only do man stuff
like what are you talking about
man people man
people
are stupid
you know what I mean
like you don't I'm telling you guys
don't have to interact with as many
people as probably I have to interact
with on a daily basis with messages or
comments and
people are legit stupid
you know what I mean
like close-minded
living in their own Universe there's no
Nuance to their thought process
just stupidity flows out of their mouth
and normally it's just in the privacy of
their home or it's like around people
who know them and they and like they go
ah man that's dominate but people put
their dumb thoughts out for the world to
see and they never think oh I wonder if
this is going to come across however
but I mean everyone does this even comic
and when you're a comic you put a joke
out and in your mind you think well this
was funny to me and then someone will
pick apart that joke and be and you're
like what that's not what I was thinking
about right so it's like it happens to
everybody you know
but it's like my God is there like
if you've been here before and by the
way welcome to the podcast for all the
people that have been here before and
all the new people and you're like what
the hell's going on this is what it is
is Eric Griffin live riffing with
Griffin I my thoughts off the top of my
head uh sometimes I'm really hilarious
sometimes I'm really serious sometimes
I'm angry Sometimes I Cry it depends on
what the subject is and sometimes we
just like talk sometimes I see a a
comment in the chat and I just think
that you know this is
you know somebody's mother didn't raise
them properly you know what I mean I
feel sad for her you know you never know
what you're gonna get
you know what I mean so but anyways
we're gonna get to my internet rant
later so let's go into uh comments you
know lots of good comments this week uh
on the podcast and on some of my
stand-up bits I'm starting to put more
stand-up bits online now I got to start
doing that because people don't even
know I'm a standard it's crazy but
people don't know I'm a stand-up you
know so I was like all right you know
what
I'm gonna start chopping stuff up put it
out there and I like putting out stand
up I I have no issue with like crowd
work because I've put out crowd work but
I realize I think everybody thinks now
that that's what stand up is the comics
just making fun of people in the crowd
and that's not really what it is it's an
art form you know it's jokes punch lines
it makes people think it makes people
mad it makes people laugh sometimes it's
silly sometimes it's like you know what
but but like I feel like we need to also
have that on the internet too so you
know and it doesn't always have to be
like a special on Netflix it's like
sometimes here here's a funny five
minute bit that I did I want to start
putting those kind of things out so
people know what I do when you come see
me I'm hilarious you come see me live
you gonna have a good time even these
troll haters they say what they want but
they're cowards they would never come up
to me at the show for the most part
they're gonna have a good time you know
what I mean those those hidden trolls
they they don't they don't even go out
they're in cells
but the ones that think they're I'm a
tough guy they're going to come to the
show and have a really great time and be
like man you're funny you know so either
way
um let's see uh comments now let's do
comments okay uh I don't even here we go
what is this on Kell Marvin I don't know
eight three six zero he goes a friend of
mine met a girl and decided to have have
decided to have her move in after five
minutes of the relationship I came to
visit and the living room there wasn't
any piece of furniture or anything that
he owned still there everything was
replaced by her
because I had this bit about like when
you move in with a girl girl moves in
with you she hates all your stuff I mean
it's true man it happens you know
uh Veronica Lopez one of the long you
know regular here at Griffin with
Griffin thank you Ronnie she said I just
wanted to give Eric a hug when he got
emotional no doubt Eric is going to be
such a great dad so excited for you and
Rachel thank you very much I appreciate
that
um
let's see anyway of course okay I'm not
that one's dumb who cares
um let's see there was one down here I
wanted to agree
uh
let's see people keep looking at the the
Lee Brothers podcast they love looking
at that one people always come to my
channel they see that one with Bobby Lee
and Steve Lee we did like we were doing
a couple of movie review podcasts for me
it was when I first started doing it and
those are like those are like really
interesting episodes of you know you
should go back and so like Marty Leon uh
gaming this is my first time watching
this episode these three together are
far better than any other current
podcast Trio
appreciate that you know
um
let's see
um oh there was one comment I really
wanted to get to
uh here's one that's like this is one
like sort of like yes and no I I just
like when people this is the kind of
comment I appreciate even if they don't
agree even if they're not agreeing with
me right so uh lucum118 said your
nuanced argument about fat shaming was
on point but your statements about lizzo
lack the same Nuance
um she she's been on British talk shows
saying how much she loves to drink and
immediately brings three hip flasks to
the Grammys to share with Adele if she's
got a drinking culture on the road then
firing dancers for drinking she needs to
sort her ish out
um that that that's very I think that's
unfair to say that like if like so what
look the issue with the lizzo situation
is she shouldn't be hanging out with her
employees
that's
that's what that is not hey
so anybody that drinks
off the job so like your CEO says to you
wherever you work I'm sure you can't
drink on the job
okay I'm sure you can't drink on the job
but wherever you work
and your boss is like hey the hell you
can't drink on the job and he's telling
you about that you drink on the job and
you get fired or if or if you're
drinking and you come to work and it's
you're drunk or it's affecting your work
your boss can be like yeah you gotta go
right
you see your boss at a bar he's having
drinks with his friends
how dumb is it to be like oh so you
drink
oh well if you drink that means you get
where I'm going with that it's not the
same thing just listen I ain't defending
whatever the culture whatever's going on
all this is nonsense like all this is
like we don't know what really is going
on with this lizzo situation okay we
don't know what really happened but what
I do know I can recognize some mistakes
that she made but the fact that she
likes to have fun and drink and she's
bringing drinks to the Grammys to share
with Adele has nothing to do with her
dancers being drunk and fat on the job
they those two things aren't mutually
exclusive so like bringing that up like
that is a false equivalency it doesn't
even make it doesn't even make sense but
I still understand the point you're
trying to make and it's because she was
a part of a culture of
wokeness you know she became a symbol of
like all this stuff that she I probably
didn't really want to live up to so
there's that part of it too but that's
the Nuance of it you know what I mean
but anyways thanks for the comment
either way agree or disagree I I
appreciate the comment
huh
let's see um and then of course you know
well I'm actually I'm glad I'm looking
at these comments because then I can
just erase
you know I could just delete people get
out of here I don't I don't I don't care
what you have to say
um
let's see I saw two of the okay so this
is rhythm
Sean I don't know Rhythm science
something or some weird ass name guy has
a long ass name that I'm not gonna sorry
okay rhythmio whatever get put your
freaking name on there all right
he said or she said I'm not I don't know
if it's he or she said I saw two of the
girls accusing lizzo and all I can say
is if those girls look drastically
different than when they were hired I
can understand but then you know I but
they might not have and if they don't
lizzo's team didn't just now figure it
out
I mean
and then she said or he said nobody
should be obligated to a happy hour it's
unpaid overtime and good reason to start
looking for another job see that's on on
my line of thinking too it's like you
you should not hang out with people that
are you're you're employing like they're
not your friend it's it's a difficult
situation and that's like if these are
girls you just auditioned and hired
unless it's your girl that you've known
for years you know then they working for
you that's different but in that
relationship is difficult you know
and I agree with you on on like yeah but
what's the margin of error for being a
dancer for lizzo
like you just made a big statement about
what you think dancers should look like
so you see these dances and you're like
whoa they already fat is what you just
said right so like what you know but
that's what's unfair to lizzo so just
because she's fat that now that means
that nobody there's no standards at all
for a professional dancer there's no
standards she's the star of the show so
she can look and feel however she wants
it's her show you know what I mean so
it's weird again there's a lot of nuance
to it but
um somebody said
beef it's what is this
BL Thomas 09 said I'll be honest with
you Eric don't look forward to back to
school too much it could be hell love my
kiddos but God damn
[Laughter]
all right you making me scared on that
one
uh uh let's see here
um
there was one comment that I was looking
for
I really want to get to it
um somebody said
so this was star girl you have to see
the go see the Barbie movie this is your
job Griffin well I did I saw it oh
here's the one
v-dub4159 okay Eric as a single mom it's
so hard to hear how the absence truly
affected the child even after all these
years I have a 13 year old son only
child dad left when he was three it's
like I'm listening to my son's inner
thoughts when you speak about it I have
his big bro from program who's great but
I know it's not enough and there's still
a huge void you're going to be a great
dad good luck to you and Rachel then
some people responded I want to respond
to this
um
you know words have power you know and
that's what you know the trolls know
that that's why they try to like that's
why they try to stab at you because
that's the only Power they have you know
this
you know but sometimes you might say
something and somebody takes it a
certain way look
every situation is different how I dealt
with my traumas or how I dealt with like
compartmentalizing and like not having
boundaries like those are things that
would have helped me realize these
things earlier but it didn't stop me
from doing what I'm doing you know yeah
you my mom was great
um I my mom's my hero I appreciate her
so much and your son will appreciate you
um it's it's not a huge it's not a huge
void it's just something I didn't
recognize
that oh so you might have feelings of
Abandonment and you don't know where
they came from so once you recognize oh
this is because there was no dad in my
life right it didn't mean that my life
was bad I just wish I would have
recognized that earlier and then it
would have changed how I how I
approached relationships it would have
changed how I approached friendships and
and then realized oh that's why I'm
feeling that way although now I can
overcome that so you know it's not like
it's it's don't blame yourself it's not
it's not it's not your fault whatever
look
this plenty of single moms out there
raising great kids there's there's two
parent families raising monsters too you
know what I mean it's all about the love
and attention that you give and I'm and
the fact that you're aware of how things
affect you how other people's
experiences you know because that's what
what's the saying dumb people make the
same mistakes smart people learn from
their mistakes brilliant people learn
from other people's mistakes so you're
attempting to be brilliant right now and
that is the sign of a great mom so I
wish you well and know that it's gonna
be okay because you're on the right
track all right
um let's see beast and this the last one
Beast bear fan people don't like hearing
opinions different from their own
I thought Eric's take on lizzo's
situation was insightful even if it
wasn't the mainstream take yeah and
that's all that I I that's all that I
want to be is like you know so thank you
so much for those comments leave your
comments and uh you know
we will uh be there oh there's the
person right in chat right now so there
you go I responded to your your message
you're doing great
um and then here's somebody in the chat
uh you know subgraph dead reckoning was
badass it was you know what I mean it
was again I'm really surprised it's not
doing is better than it's doing right
now so but anyways let's go into some
stuff now that I wanted to talk about
and I'll tell you why I wanted to talk
about certain things uh and and this is
exactly like kind of on the same subject
of like this mom hitting me up you know
but here's an example of something that
made me think about what I'm going to
talk about in terms of the internet man
internet's a scary place man so this
doctor reveals mouthwash raises blood
pressure you know so he has this whole
video that he goes into you know what I
mean where he talks about I wonder if we
can let me see if you guys can hear the
video then I'll I'll play it why not you
know let's see where where is it hello
oh man what's going on here
I wait we can't hear it I can't hear it
either that's the crazy part
you know I don't know how to
did I mute this where's the sound
anyways this is so this is always what
happens but anyways he's saying how
mouthwash kills bacterias and you know
but
you know he's basically talking about
so
this is what this made me think of
you know it's like there are so much
information on the internet like so much
you know and so you see this and you go
well who's this guy how do we fact check
him is he an expert is this something
that is like is this out there do I
start googling this now is this like a
real thing it's like is mouthwash bad
for you and you know
you could be on edge all the time about
things you see on the internet man
you know this is one of those things
where you go well who's this doctor is
he a kook you know is this like a
reputable source
and then now you're looking at your
mouthwash like damn do I not need this
and it's like
it's like how do you take things with a
grain of salt you know how do you like
decipher
or differentiate between like well this
is just a kook or hey make sure you do
your own research because that might not
be uh you know
the right thing as opposed to
you know what is this but the thing is
like how do you do your own research
because what if you're Googling like hey
you know mouthwash and then this guy
comes up you know at some you know he
works at the he's a doctor at such and
such the Mayo Clinic or whatever it is
and you go well I believe this guy you
know you know what I mean and it's just
like you just get some Instagram post
with information and you just go man how
do you how do you figure this out right
and it just made me think about
being a father man and getting all of
this
information about kids on you know as
these posts on Instagram you know so
we're getting information from people
it's like there's a lot of great posts
it'll be like a mom going like three
things I wish I knew as a first-time mom
and it'll be like you should buy this
this and this uh and then you'll see all
these different uh sort of like experts
quote unquote and they'll have like
about like for instance swaddling you
know you know it's like where you like
wrap the baby up like a burrito
and that helps them feel comfortable and
they sleep better or whatever the
thought is with that so you have a
school of thought to be like yeah you
got to swaddle it'll help you help the
kids and then there's just like then
there'll be this new thing you'll see
and they'll be like turns out
swaddling's not good
I think you're sitting here as a parent
now and you're like what well which one
is it you know and then it's like
there'll be another thing that comes up
and it's a post about don't kiss your
baby
kissing babies are bad because their
immune system is not ready for this that
and this and that you know and you're
like oh my God and then you'll see
another post and it's like you know
they're passing the baby around
everybody's kissing the baby you're like
okay which one is it you know and then
it's like there's another guy I saw you
know he's you know well put together
video and he's like you know you don't
know what Wi-Fi and Wi-Fi devices do to
your child and you're like what and he's
like so he's like Wi-Fi cameras you know
don't have these near the baby and
you're like oh my God he's like get some
what get some electromagnetic whatever
it was called some kind of netting or
put tin foil underneath the the you know
you're just like what is this then
there's another one about like you know
you know not having a crib you know I
saw like the babies just on a mattress
on the ground you know so you like you
know you make sure everything's safe
around this and the baby's just sort of
wandering at night crawling and trying
to see oh I want to play no actually I
want to sleep you know and then there's
like so then there's studies about I
just saw another one another uh
Instagram sort of video the the they're
showing it's you know about a study they
were having about uh how you praise your
children and then one was it was very
fascinating because he said
when you say like hey you did the best
you can or great job uh you know you
know that was a great effort when you
give effort praise as opposed to being
like you're so smart you're the best how
that actually it doesn't make them work
harder it was this whole thing where I
was like oh my God how do you do it it's
my question for you parents out there
how do you do it how do you maneuver
through how do you figure out what's the
best thing with all of this information
coming at our heads man it's like my God
even something as small as
the doctor reveals mouthwash raises
blood pressure you know you see that but
I'll say one thing I love about Rachel
is she's all over this kind of stuff in
turn like we have organic we have this
weird deodorant that's like a cream I
love it though but it's very no
artificial whatever's in it and you know
it's like you you did you you know and
it really works you know I don't you
know at the end of the day I'm smelling
my underarms like okay this works good
as opposed to when you use regular
deodorant and then like you hear about
you hear these studies about deodorant
what that does to use and you're kind of
like oh my God now I can't use deodorant
but Rachel's all about that like we we
vote we she hasn't been using we haven't
been using mouthwash with alcohol for a
while because she has this you know she
goes to Sprouts or one of those crazy
places and she's like this is the
mouthwash I like you know and I go okay
you know we get some weird [__] from Air
One or whatever you know and so she's
all over that kind of stuff the
toothpaste the toothpaste we have is
organic it's this weird brand uh the
shampoos and lotions and things that we
use are made from this particular
company that you know it's all natural
you know so she's all over that kind of
stuff which I appreciate because I
wouldn't even know what to do but who
even knows if that stuff is correct
right Rachel's hair is everywhere
I'll be on the road and be like it might
be like some long-ass hair of hers
anyway
tangent so the internet is like listen I
love the internet
I love it and hate it it's probably the
greatest and the worst thing to ever
happen to our society right but there
are good things I love reaching out to
authors I listen to a lot of audiobooks
I read books and if I really enjoy it I
reach out to the author and be like I
loved this book
thumbs up you know I even when I listen
to an audiobook and I the person reading
is doing such a great job with voices
and stuff I'll reach out to them on the
Internet and be like hey love that love
what you did you know love your work and
for the most part people love that kind
of Praise because you know they you know
they don't even know people are
listening you know like you you're
reading an audiobook and the author's
getting all the credit for everything
and you know no you know you're the job
you're doing you just kind of go okay
and somebody reaches out and it's like
hey you really made this pop I think
that's great for people so you have that
part of the internet that's great you
know when when I get praised people are
like hey I think you're funny I love
this joke you know but also there are
people who enjoy chaos you know there's
people who enjoy chaos they enjoy riling
people up uh you know they enjoy
trolling there's people that just enjoy
trolling it's their life you know so
that's good for them that's the part
they like they like go into a Comics
chat or a podcaster that they don't like
or whatever and they love like being
like yeah you're the you know whatever
they're gonna say they love that you
know it's like there's this guy on
Twitter
um who like no matter what I tweet he
puts a pic he puts a picture of Target
some Target picture you know what I mean
so like a couple times I thought it was
funny and I like even responded with
like hashtag Target family you know
thinking like oh he no no this guy legit
is trying to be
an [__]
there's one thing you're just trying to
be funny but this so I was like ah oh
okay well now you gotta go so I BL for
the first time in like years I blocked
somebody
because I was like ah you know what I
don't want to deal with this anymore so
you just block them you know but it's
it's fine though I'm not I'm not a I'm
not mad at that this is what the this is
what gets this guy off so like thumbs up
to him so I get it he that's he feels
empowered because and that's what the
internet that's what it is but the thing
is
the internet's too absolute
it's too headline
like you know this is the headline and
there's no Nuance man I don't believe
that when you put people in a room and
they really discuss a a hot button issue
I don't believe that they believe the
absolute information that comes out on
the internet the headlines the things a
lot of people want to get mad about you
know I think if you get everybody if you
get people in a room and have a
discussion No One's Gonna say being fat
is okay no one
no one thinks being fat is okay you know
everyone would think
that it's better to be healthy to so you
can live longer so you can have less
broad all the all the negatives of being
out of shape and overweight we all agree
with them
but when you're a part of a narrative
you have to put out this nonsense that
they you don't believe it
you know you like stop you don't believe
that stuff you believe that we should be
nice to people and you believe that
there's a way to communicate things but
you don't like when when there's some
fat girl on Instagram going I'm
beautiful y'all it's like no she don't
even believe that okay nobody believes
that but on the internet we have to put
out absolutes
nobody if you if you've got even the
most staunch transgender activist in a
room with people having a nuanced
discussion about trans women in sports I
guarantee you the discussion in that
private non-internet environment is
going to be about yeah yes there is
something wrong with what's happening
when trans women are playing sports with
with CIS women or whatever the term is
even though those people know nobody
believes that nobody believes that this
is okay and we have to figure it out and
there's a nuanced way there's a there's
a have an open conversation about it but
when it's on the internet it has to be
absolute you know on the other side
in terms of in the environment and
global warming I think if you got
some staunch right-wing person you got
him in a room they're intelligent enough
to have like a conversation about yes we
probably we should do something better
about the environment you know I I don't
think they believe that oh there's no no
such thing as global war nobody come on
man 99 all scientists are telling us we
are doing something to the environment
and let's work it out this it's not
extreme there's Nuance to it discuss it
you know like did Biden steal the
election you know that kind of stuff you
just go what you don't really believe
that you know what I mean like it's like
the
I just think that there's all these sort
of like big topics that people discuss
on the internet in a way that it has to
be you're a racist you're terrible
you're this or or these big time topics
and we we fight about it you know as
opposed to discussing it having a
nuanced
conversation
you know what I mean
and
that's what
why the internet is like
great and it's also terrible and as you
know
a a a future parent
what are you supposed to believe the
information's
overwhelming you know
information is overwhelming and somebody
said I see someone in the comment Eric
has always been this though I agree with
you I agree that I agree that like even
when it was only three news networks and
it was newspapers and magazines I
believe that
uh there was less information out there
even if those people were still doing
that but I feel like
I feel like
because there's so much information we
get everyone's opinion now now we're
just like we're letting things
flow through that are like we're just
missing things like are there aliens and
we're just not talking about it you know
and so uh just to move on there's
another
um
there there's another story that like
that I feel like man this should be
something we should be talking about
more man
potential cancer breakthrough has
groundbreaking pill annihilates all
types of solid tumors in early study
when I hear that I go
why are we talking about
anything else right
like this is amazing
even just to praise these people of
being like
you know
hey
what up
like good job tell us more maybe this is
where you know you want to send your
money to help you know with the research
how we doing here you know I just think
that this I hope that this is true
you know the article says the pill works
by targeting a protein present in most
cancers which helps tumors grow and
multiply with the body this discovery is
being defined as groundbreaking by many
as a protein proliferating cell nuclear
agent psna was previously thought to be
undegradable
I mean so they're making
huge breakthroughs in medical and we're
just sitting around not even realizing
this is going on because it's probably
not touching us like I'm a part of like
all any kind of Neuroscience stuff about
the brain any kind of research in
Alzheimer's and Dementia I get the
newsletter and I'm looking at it man I'm
seeing where are we at with this and
it's because it's personal to me so I'm
sure there's people out there that like
cancer has touched your life
you know maybe you know you lost someone
or maybe someone has it and you just
look at this and you just go man we're
like we're getting close to really
making breakthroughs man so
you know look out for that kind of stuff
too I I hope I hope that that's true
um
you know I hope that that's true man you
know what I mean so all right weird
weird stories of the day before we get
to the topic of the day which was the
Barbie movie I just I saw this and I
thought this is like what is this man do
you guys see this this Chinese zoo is
forced to deny its Bears or humans in
costumes
like
what
like why would you do this
right
it's like are we at Disneyland
like are these bears like what's going
on like
what kind of bear is this a real bear or
is this
somebody in in a um
in a costume doesn't that look crazy
like are there no more maybe they've
killed all the animals what is the
purpose of this
you know you're like
I don't even know what I even want to
say about this I'm so flustered I'm so
flustered by this
like I wonder if they did it like it
says a zoo in China has refused to uh
grin and bear it after a video of one of
the bears standing on his hind legs went
viral forcing officials to deny it was a
human in costume
[Laughter]
like is this a real bear
is this a real bear like you let oh God
do I you know what let's do this we're
gonna put a poll up and if you if you're
listening right now on Apple and thank
you for listening on for every wherever
you get your podcast and you listen you
know I appreciate that
um
you know
it's like
you guess it just it looks like you're
at Disneyland and this guy's walking
around in a bear suit and kids are
walking up to it to take a picture you
know that that's what that's what this
looks like it's the weirdest thing I've
ever seen you know it's like and then
this you know this and of course does
how gangster would it be just to be like
look yeah it's a guy we're sorry you
know we're running out of animals and
the Bear exhibit is one of our hot
topics it's right in the area that we
gotta have bears in there so you know we
have a guy go in and be a bear like you
know just own it
who would care that's the thing
who's going to the zoo getting a refund
you know you walking up being like like
that ain't a real bear give me my twelve
dollars back
I'm sure you still saw other animals
there was other stuff there they just
wanted to make sure you had a good time
with the bear I mean I just it's a show
right
first of all a zoo is horrible anyway
actually this is better for the the
animals you know you like how crazy that
we we capture animals and put them in a
a a an enclosure for our enjoyment and
then people are getting on this Zoo for
for having like a human being in a bear
suit making people think it's a real
animal this is like going to Pirates of
the Caribbean at Disneyland or something
like who cares
somebody said Martin Leon and chat it's
a real bear I know that guy personally
uh it's like well this is what this I
don't know this reminds me of
Workaholics you know what I mean
you know you know what I mean so it's
like that's just it was just it's just
one of those weird stories on the
internet
um all right let's go to another bizarre
story on the internet this one was like
you know in the weird AI in the weird AI
stuff man and I love AI you know I
didn't make my description with AI this
week guys I made it myself so it's
probably terrible but like oh I'll tell
you can I let me give you an AI tip and
I'm not even
they're not even they're not even a
sponsor I'm just saying this there's
this new app called perplexity and
Google has its own version too called
bard b-a-r-d
but I'ma tell you what I like about it
you go to Bar it's the follow-up
questions so it's a new sort of uh
internet search so now you can search
for something with AI
and then you could do a follow-up search
on that search so maybe you're like uh
what's the you know
you know what's the what's the most
common bear found in in the wild you
know and they say this blah blah blah
and you go then you could follow up like
well do the will those bears attack if
you go to this particular Campground and
then they then they'll be like oh well
you know from the news blah blah blah
that Campground seems to be safe and you
should probably be careful and then
they'll give you some things that you
can look at and you can just keep going
with like sort of like having a
conversation with your search engine and
I think that that's great so like even
if like you let's say you're looking for
an airline flight you're like hey what
are the cheapest flights to Vegas you
know and then they say yeah they go well
is are these flights full or you know
what I mean like you could do follow-up
questions so I think you should look out
for that there's a few of them one of
them is called perplexity and the other
one's um barred on Google's like sort of
like beta testing this search engine but
I think all of those kinds of things
like Twitter Instagram they're all gonna
have like a sort of AI helper even like
website like this website program I use
so I'm gonna make a new website but like
it's said like it has an AI part of it
and you go well what are you making this
website for so I put comedian
and then it said oh we'll hear the pages
you should have I mean they created
Pages like uh tour dates bio and it's
like based off the AI algorithm right so
I think that there's like something to
that but here's in the weird category of
AI is this this tick tocker
an Asian woman asked AI to improve her
headshot and it turned her white
this is oh no what improved her head
shot oh man dude tell me the AI is white
without telling me the AI is white
well that's like if you're if the AI
becomes sentient and they're looking at
all the stuff that's going on in the
world and they're getting all the news
articles and they're like well you know
if you really want to work in this world
girl you got to be white
that's what the AI That's what the AI
did the air I was like well you gonna
have trouble being Asian uh from from
from from what we've studied from what
I've the AI was like well from what
we've gathered about the world right now
you'll be better off being a white woman
like
oh man
this this is let's chalk this under the
AI needs some work okay
the AI needs some like like yeah
that's that's
but that's all I'm gonna say about that
um and then all right oh real quick
because like we're getting so I love Big
Brother Big Brother's back it's a hot
mess I'll make this quick because I want
to get to Barbie
um so this guy like there's this guy on
Big Brother the new cast so you know you
can watch Big Brother
like you can watch Big Brother like uh
on Paramount plus you can see the live
feeds so this it's just like the people
in the Big Brother house
right now you could go to it and look
and see what they're doing it's part of
the Big Brother experience you get
Paramount plus and you know and then
that's what big brother is it's 16
cameras and they're watching the people
24 hours a day well this guy you know
he's just
he forgot he's on camera he's having a
conversation this is how he talks in
real life you know I listen I ain't
gonna I'm not gonna just I'm not gonna
just get on this dude like he's the
racist it's like when you're in your
privacy of your home just like when
you're in a car and a rap song comes on
and the m word is flying you in your car
and you saying whatever the words are
and so it I believe like this is one of
those situations you know and you know
and he got caught and he immediately was
like oh I'm on camera I'm sorry they
would since remove the video but he was
just saying it in a in a sentence like
he probably normally talks at home in
front of with his friends you know and
so I don't know if I don't I don't
necessarily think the guy's racist it's
just one of those words that it's like
so polarizing and so they had they
kicked him off the show you know they
kicked the one they kicked the one of
the sort of good looking straight white
guys off the show that that probably had
a chance to win oh let me get my quick
thoughts on Big Brother is this man and
I've said this in the past when I talk
about Big Brother
I don't know what the hell they're doing
okay look to me big brother is best when
it's 16
super attractive people acting horrible
to try to win a million dollars okay or
whatever the prize money is we want to
see pretty people hooking up trying to
win money and Big Brother brings the
worst out of people's personality okay
we that's what we want to see
when you bring regular people in
this the nicest way I'm gonna say that
okay regular ass people I don't want to
see
the girl that works at the post office
acting horrible on TV this is escapism
and so now it's all about like well we
have to have you know the every man and
and what I don't appreciate about
appreciate about it is like
they ugly y'all let me just why am I
bullshitting it's like this it's too
many like it's too many air Griffins on
this show you know what I mean when I'm
on a show
I'm like I'm always like fifth to eighth
lead on a show I'm in that category you
got the leading man the leading woman
the kids the friends whatever and then
I'm the guy I'm the funny guy I come in
you don't want to see a a reality show
of just me it's like come on and on this
show they got like these three sort of
really fit hunky white boys who are
gonna win okay because I because of the
the skills Challenge and the endurance
and the physical element of Big Brother
which is a huge part of it and then
you've got these people who you're like
who the hell is this
they don't got
I don't know what they're doing
that's just my opinion okay I'm entitled
to my opinion you're entitled to yours
but it's like it's like the agenda of
like we gotta stop man
sometimes it's okay to have pretty
people sometimes it's okay to have
pretty white people too like it's like
it's not
and if you gonna have different people
can we get the cream like you know
there's pretty of any because this is an
image it's a it's TV
this isn't real I don't want to see real
live that's why watch it's escapism it's
uh
I'm you know what I mean this is like my
guilty pleasure
my guilty pleasure is not going to the
post office and watching regular Folk
maybe that's just me maybe I'm a monster
call me a monster I don't care all right
y'all let's get to it
let's get to it
no spoilers could be I don't know Barbie
I saw the Barbie movie and I have
um some thoughts on it
um
Okay so
you know Barbie it's like the fastest
movie to a billion dollars I think ever
I think that's one of the things I heard
about the Barbie movie
um
you know actually I'm gonna go to this
bard
so you guys and I will ask bar you know
I'll I'll show you the prompts right now
uh is Barbie the fastest movie to reach
one billion
you know
you know you ask it and then it'll say
oh it's not no Barbie is not the fastest
movie to reach 1 billion as of August to
9th 2023 the fastest movie to a billion
is Avengers Infinity War okay makes
sense which did it in 11 days Barbie
reached 1 billion in 17 days making it
the eighth fastest movie to reach a
billion oh that's great and then they
have the facts right here uh you know
it's it's yeah it's great
um
that's that's how you do that you know
but it is the fastest uh female directed
movie to reach a billion dollars and
it's like the most popular movie right
now so hey look look at quick fact check
right there with Bard and then you could
do follow-up questions which is great so
we went to go see Barbie I didn't want
to see it without Rachel you know but I
did want to see it for the podcast
purposes and I was fascinated to like go
buy everybody so you know what's this
movie so I'll give you my thoughts all
right first of all I'm watching it and
the first part of the movie I was just
turned off I was like what is this it
just felt woke you know and it just it
just felt like there was an agenda right
at first so there was like uh what is
this you know there's a girl in a
wheelchair anytime I see somebody in a
wheelchair in a movie in a dance scene
I'm like what are we doing you know
that's my initial thought only because
it's like how how we're so over
correcting all the time on everything no
shade on people in wheelchairs it's like
good for you you know good good you know
but it's like that's just the thought it
gives you because of the society we're
living in right right now this sort of
like you know I'm a good person police
right
and so then I'm just I'm watching and
it's very weird movie it's not like in
reality you know
um because I always wonder like what are
they gonna do right
and then and then I'm watching and then
there's parts of it where I'm just kind
of like I don't know who this is for I
didn't know what it was you know I look
over at Rachel she's captivated and some
of the jokes were funny like a lot of
the jokes were funny a lot of the jokes
were just like stale jokes you know joke
all those like old school jokes that
women say about men you know it's like
you know all men like the Good Fellas
and you know you know what I mean like
all those kind of jokes oh really this
is the jokes it's like we're stale ass
and Men jokes right uh and then there's
parts of it like Will Ferrell was funny
and
um uh I thought Helen Mirren as the
narrator she said some really funny
lines you know it was very the movie was
very aware of itself Margot Robbie did a
great job as being this sort of abstract
character as being this like
it was it was well done in terms of that
right and then by the end of the movie I
was like oh and but I'll tell you my my
genuine thoughts about it is
I realized that this movie wasn't for me
like literally like not even speaking my
language and what do I mean by that like
when you watch most movies that I like I
like action movies I like action movies
I like comedies and a lot of these types
of movies are centered around men action
movies are about men doing man [__] you
know and if there is a woman in the
movie it'll be like oh she's this strong
character but it's still surrounded by
men doing stuff for men right
um if even if it's a love story women
like love story The Love Story is about
a woman trying to get a man and then and
then the end it's about her getting the
man right so there's always a man
involved
I realized I'm looking at Barbie and I'm
like oh this isn't for me this is like a
movie that literally was speaking to
women
like
speaking whatever language it is that
they understand uh whatever that's just
my takeaway of it I felt like they this
wasn't for men
but that doesn't mean that we don't
watch it it's not meaning like just like
in the same way a woman could go see
Avengers and have a good time you can go
to this movie and have a good time and
you just lose yourself into like
whatever this message they're trying to
send and just enjoy the parts of the
movie but there just were moments into
what I was like you know I look over at
Rachel and she's crying at something and
I'm like oh okay you know I I'm looking
around the theater and I'm seeing like
you know girls laughing and you know
women with their daughters and they're
just like enjoying moments that I'm just
kind of looking at it and being like
okay all right cool right but that's
like and I thought oh well that's great
I thought if I had a daughter I would
want to take her to see this movie
I would be like oh is this empowering to
to to some to some women probably you
know there was like a speech that um
what's her name America is that her name
whatever the star one of the stars of
the movie she made that I was like huh
you know and I feel like she was
speaking two women Four Women and as a
guy you're listening and you go okay
like we would have our side you know
what I mean and they tried to show a
little bit of that right with with 10
and then what was going on with the Ken
world and all that but it was still
through the prism and perspective
[Music]
um
you know you know four women you know
what I mean
I mean like it's it's abstract just like
the movie was you know I guess I'm not
saying that the movie was made I'm not
saying that the movie was made for women
and only women to watch that's not what
I'm saying I'm saying it was it's a
movie made for women like this is like
finally it's like no this movie doesn't
have to be about men it doesn't have to
be a woman trying to get a man all that
was deliberate like like there's there's
deliberate things happen in this movie
where it's like no no this is a movie
for women like in the same way that like
when you go see a a you know some kind
of like a guy overcoming and getting
revenge and you're like yeah I know how
that feels and maybe a woman goes to the
movies she might be like well I don't
feel the same way but I enjoyed this
movie I'm saying I enjoyed the movie
I enjoyed the movie I'm not trying to
get into some political thing right now
I'm not you don't you know you're not
understanding if you're not
understanding what I'm saying I actually
don't care
I'm saying that I believe that this
woman this movie was made in a language
that women understand better than men do
and the message that men were supposed
to receive is a message that we receive
from women all the time about like the
patriarchy and like you know how we that
message is is out there already you know
but this is like the messaging and the
voice of the the movie is like a great
voice a great female voice
you know
um
you know what I mean
it's like
I well somebody's like this is such a
fascinating question in the chat right
now it's like it's just a movie why go
this deep into it because it's a [__]
podcast [__] and that's what you
[__] do on a podcast like that's what
I'm saying right there
this is what this is this is what you
watch because I'm riffing with Griffin
and I talk about [__] and I get deep
with it that's why what do you mean what
do you mean why you [__] you think
you're watching like people are so crazy
anyway
real moment I just had right there
um anyways and I really enjoyed
that part
of the movie so when I left it and I was
like oh there were Parts I didn't like
there were Parts I thought were funny
and then there were Parts I thought was
like you know the Imaging of it and uh
you know as a comic I enjoyed the jokes
some of the jokes and some of the jokes
I was like Ah that's corny but I I
enjoyed other ones and at the end of the
day I was like oh that was an enjoyable
movie but as I thought about I was like
well what was this about or why what was
the point of this or why everybody's so
fascinated about it and I think it's
like
like I said I think it was like a great
movie
that was
in a voice for women you know it was
great you know and and I think a lot of
times there could be more movies like
this like I had a review of Black Widow
I enjoyed Black Widow
you know the Scarlett Johansson produced
one because it was like oh she was the
star it was it was like like the
emotions that women bring to things and
it had that and the action so I was like
this it made it made for a great movie I
I liked that you know and I was like oh
I think movies could could benefit from
having this in it having this voice but
you know this movie had a particular
there was a message that was supposed to
be
you know put out right but I think
moving forward there could be other
movies that are just you know focused on
focused on a female voice if that makes
sense you know but anyways
anyways uh yeah the female the male
version of this was GI Joe
[Laughter]
yeah I mean anyways guys uh I appreciate
you being here as always uh you know
this is how we do here oh and you know
and I thought like I say I thought
Barbie was great and I'll give it like
you know eight woo-woos
there we go
um let's see uh what what
oh sorry and we're you know we're good
we're done you know you know what we do
we do it old man style as always it's
time for the old man beats
oh man flows
I like my guy fishy let's see another
one of his songs but as always thank you
for watching riffing with Griffin I
appreciate you uh you know make sure you
subscribe make sure you share make sure
you uh
come back hit me on Twitch hit me on the
patreon and uh as always I appreciate
you guys coming every week to read from
what Griffin if you're here for the
first time thank you you know but as we
do
always at this time
we hit you with that
[Music]
fishy
did it again
[Music]
went to a movie with my friend
she's my wife
the love of my life
nothing rhymes with Barbie
should have went to RB
movie was good
it was fresh there's fishy beats give
them a chat
doing it right
uh they made that Asian white internet
check your neck foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right y'all thanks for coming thanks
for watching rifle with Griffin
if you want to send a beat Eric at
ericgirlfriend.com
[Music]
um love y'all even the trolls
and I see you next week
[Music]